hello belief nation I'm Evan Carmichael
my one word is believe and I believe
that entrepreneurs are going to solve
all of the world's major problems I
started to mentor me series with the
goal to try to learn from people who've
done a lot more than as people who have
done amazing things that by spending a
little bit more time with them hopefully
some of their values their belief
systems their way of thinking seeped
into us to help us become the best
version of ourselves so to help you on
your journey today we're going to learn
from Robin Sharma and some of his best
leadership motivation mentor me Robin
and as always guys when you're watching
if you hear something that really
resonates with you please leave it down
in the comments below and vocals around
it to other people can be inspired as
well and when you write it down it's
much more likely to stick with yourself
to enjoy
[Music]
you
I've spent so much of the past 20 years
of my life evangelizing a message that
leadership is not about a title
leadership is not about the size of your
office leadership is not about having
formal Authority leadership is a mindset
leadership is a way of operating through
your days leadership is a heart set
leadership is a way of a being and I
think you know we're now in leadership
2.0 the old model of leadership said you
need to have a lot of money or you need
to be a prime minister or President you
need to be a CEO or Managing Director in
order to be a leader leadership 2.0 is
fundamentally different leadership 2.0
simply says if you can breathe if you
are alive you not only have the
opportunity you have the responsibility
to show leadership not only in your work
not only in your creativity not only in
your impact not only in your influence
but even in your personal life so let's
get right to the first tactic for you to
be an even better leader install the
lead without a title mindset and again
that's just a way of thinking it's an
approach so what I'm really suggesting
is no matter what you do no matter what
your station in life is start thinking
like a leader because you really have a
choice when you go out in the world
every day you can be a victim or you can
be a leader but you can't do both and so
the more you practice showing leadership
in your work showing leadership with
your family showing leadership in your
community showing leadership in your
private self practice drives performance
and the more you practice it the more
you start to step into the mindset of a
leader without a title our world says
that if you are a leader in many ways
it's about what you get what I'm going
to suggest you a deep respect
being a leader is about what you give
and it's a paradox because as you give
more you actually receive more but again
Society has sold us this methodology and
this philosophy that if we get from the
world if we get more income if we get
more from our clients if we get more
from our employees if we get four more
from
sectors if we get more from society we
will feel happy we will be successful we
will be at the top of the mountain we
will live these epic awesome and
fulfilling lives
and I don't believe that's the case and
I haven't experienced that to be the
case at all to me if you give and you
are a humble instrument of service
everything just falls into place and so
what I wanted to do is really start off
by talking about the new economy the old
economy was an economy of scarcity it
was like there's not enough in the world
so how can I get as much as possible
before it's all gone the new economy
that we do business in and that we live
life in is one not of scarcity but it's
about generosity and I think the person
who gives the most wins and that's just
the world we live in right now whether
you believe this or not so what I'm
going to challenge you to do is simply
I'm going to walk you through some
insights right now let's start thinking
about this what if Robin is right the
strangest paradox of leadership is not
about what I give the strangest paradox
of leadership is as I serve more and
help more people I not only become more
I actually receive more the first things
I want to offer to you and I call it the
10 x value obsession just make a brain
tattoo sort of a psychological wiring
that you practice until the point it's
unconscious and automatic which is this
how can I give my customers ten times
the value that they have any right to
expect so whatever it is whatever
product you pour into the world how can
that product give them ten times the
value that they're expecting that
dominant mindset and way of being has
colossal consequences you see most
people can talk the talk they don't walk
it they talk the talk I want to give I
want to WoW my customers I want to give
great products I want to give a great
user experience great customer service
maybe even to their friends they talk a
good game but there's a misalignment
between their vocabulary that they're
expressing publicly and their actual
internal intent
and when there is a misalignment with
what you say and what you truly feel
even if what you truly feel is
subconscious you don't even know it
people feel it so the first idea on this
10x value of session you really want to
come from a place where you actually
feel I need to be an instrument of
service Robin is right I want to be a
giver versus a taker I want to give
these people who put food on my table
that I call my customers ten times the
value they have any right to expect and
once once that becomes your emotional
and your dominant way of being people
feel it and it changes your behavior and
it changes your performance you actually
go the extra mile you actually start to
up your products are not mediocre your
products are masterful your team is not
average your team becomes iconic why
because you're coming from that deep
emotional passionate place that is far
more powerful than the cold hard logic
up let us make our numbers so that we
satisfy our shareholders number three I
call it the three I practice the three I
practice if you want to be a better
leader understand and then practice
these three eyes
number one inspiration the job of a
leader really is to inspire other people
if you look at Steve Jobs you look at
Elon Musk you look at Nelson Mandela you
look at Sergey Brin of Google you look
at a rembrandt or or Picasso these
people were incredibly inspired there
were not only incredibly inspired they
were inspirational to other people I
mean there's that incredible story of
Steve Jobs and a lot of people say Steve
Jobs wasn't a nice person and yet if you
were to pull the former employees of
Apple they would say my years at Apple
working with Steve Jobs were the single
best years of my entire career
and you say why and they say because he
was inspirational I mean when Steve Jobs
was a young man or a young kid you know
his father said go out and paint the
fence outside of their house and Steve
Jobs said no problem he went out and he
started painting the outside of the
fence
a few hours later his father comes out
and says Steve did you paint defense
Steve says I did that Steve Jobs his
father inspects the fence and he says
Steve you did a great job painting the
outside of the fence but you didn't
paint the inside of the fence if Steve
Jobs looked up at his father and says
but Dad no one's going to see the inside
of the fence and his father looks at
them and says but son
we will now it's many decades later and
Steve Jobs is running Apple and they're
ready to launch already to develop
rather the first Apple Macintosh he
looked at the design team and he said
here's your deliverable I want the
outside of the computer to look so
simple and so elegant like a piece of
art but here's the real mission make the
inside so beautiful that it'll bring
tears to our eyes and his design team
looked at him and said but Steve no
one's going to see the inside of the
Apple Macintosh and Steve Jobs looked at
his team and said but we will
that's inspiration I think the only
title that really matters is CIO chief
inspirational officer so no matter what
you do whether you're a teacher or
firefighter an astronaut or an
entrepreneur maybe you're managing
director maybe your mother or a father
be the CIO the chief inspirational
officer of all you do the second eye at
the three I practice to make you an
amazing leader is influence influence
you want to be so good at what you do
that you influence other people you want
to use the words in the language of
leadership versus victim speak you want
to influence people by your mindset by
your heart say you want to influence
people by your thinking patterns you
want to influence people by your
productivity so you want to influence
people and that's the job of a leader
and then the third eye if the third eye
practice impact less talk more do no
matter what your title is you know
you're leading you know you're winning
when you are creating impact you know a
lot of people in the world and victims
to do this they talk about what they're
going to do here's the project I'm going
to launch here's a marathon I'm going to
run here's the life I'm going to crash
but they don't execute impact is about
translating your ideas to execution and
so the fourth leadership lesson is being
deep versus be light be deep I mean this
is a gorgeous opportunity to build a
monopoly of mastery within your industry
I mean you want to be so good at what
you do that when we watch you in action
tears come to our eyes people rise to
their feet and applaud you and how do
you do that well you separate yourself
from the way most people operate in
business and in life you go deep we live
in a world that is really suffering from
the cult of superficiality everything is
fast everything is quick everything is
light imagine you resolve today I will
be deep when I do work when I work on a
project when I build a client
relationship when I work with a personal
relationship when I install a new habit
it's not going to be light I'm not going
to be superficial I'm going to go deep
I'm going to bring rigor to my game
let's say you're installing a new habit
let's say it's my famous 5 a.m. Club you
start reading all the literature on the
neurobiology of early rising you
actually read all of the books on habit
installation you actually find a coach
let's say to help you install the 5 a.m.
routine you actually build that a
protocol to mark your progress I'm just
saying could you imagine rather than
going very wide in your work or very
wide in your personal life you dial it
in with a monomaniacal focus to be
genius level at just a few things
that's rigor and rigor is really an
approach I was in lousier in Switzerland
a few months ago and I'm I was working
on my new book and someone delivered
some tea and I had asked her some fresh
lemon and what I noticed is whoever had
sliced the lemons took the
to de-seed the lemon wedges and that's
originally your metaphor for this
podcast you know that's what you know
this lesson is all about it the fourth
leadership lesson be deep versus be
light it's about deseeding the lemon
wedges on the earring as a focus that
are most important to you anyone can
just cut the lemon wedges and hand them
to you but this producer had the
discipline the bravery the acumen the
commitment the devotion to actually take
the time to deceive the lemon wedges
there is incredible and indelible
influence and imprinting going on on
your philosophy and on your mind when
you read a book so you have a
conversation with someone and I'm sure
you've got a conversation maybe it's
with a chef or a great entrepreneur or
wise human being and that maybe it was
just one conversation but that person in
that 10 minute conversation or hour-long
conversation said something to you that
forms your philosophy that changed the
rest of your life well that's what you
can get in a book you can have a
conversation tonight with Kanye you can
have a conversation
the next night with Edison you can have
a conversation two nights from now with
Nelson Mandela you can read the
biography that I recently read off a
Elon Musk you know Rican you can read
about Steve Jobs you can read about
Vincent van Gogh's life you can read
about Martin Luther King Jr's life you
can read about the titans of industry
and what they went through and how they
innovated and how they dealt with
struggles and how they dealt with wealth
you can read books on productivity from
the most productive people on the planet
you can learn how people who build
companies like IKEA and Red Bulls how
they did it they took a small idea and
built it into an empire so what I'm
suggesting to you with great love and
respect as I always do in these mastery
sessions is reading a book is nothing
more than having a conversation with the
author and you can spend your evening
this or morning's or afternoons or lunch
times connecting with the greatest minds
who have ever graced the planet you
cannot put a price tag on that
if you hire c-level people please don't
be surprised if you have a D level
company if you truly want an iconic
business one that stands the test of the
generation one where you build what I
call a globally cherished brand then you
absolutely must make it your dominant
obsession to hire and manage and retain
and engage only a level performers the
best leaders on the planet grow other
leaders so if you're not growing leaders
faster than your peers you're not
leading your following I'm going to
repeat that again the job of the leader
is to grow more leaders so yes do your
work yes become more creative yes
innovate yes optimize your personal life
and yet at the same time make the time
to develop leaders around you what that
might look like at the office
celebrating a teammate at the office
that might look like modeling mastery at
the office it might look like
collaborating with someone who needs
some collaboration at home what does
growing the leaders look like well I
might be mentoring your children
exposing them to art giving them great
books it might mean being a positive
force in your home life so the job of
the leader is to grow more leaders one
of the things I observe is simply this
a lot of people are very careless with
their language and so you know there's a
huge shift you can either be a victim or
you can be a leader but you can't be
both and if you look at someone who is a
victim a lot of their victimhood comes
down to the words they use I mean the
words you use either lift up your energy
the words you use either make you more
creative the words you use either allow
you to do world-class things or the
words you use deny your talents the
words you use could reduce your energy
the words you use could hurt your
leadership so you have a choice every
day at work and at home and out on the
streets with strangers you can
evolve a victim vocabulary or the
language of leadership and in this
mastery session I want to walk you
through some of my insights on those
well words are powerful I mean words
have destroyed nations I mean think
about the great dictators their words of
hatred their words of toxicity their
words of breakdown cause the people
around them to do sometimes incredibly
terrifying acts and then you look at
people like a Nelson Mandela or Martin
Luther King jr. or mother Teresa you
look at the great business builders you
look at humanitarians you look at a lot
of the great artists and they were so
careful with their words and their words
lifted people up and that's really what
great leaders do they use the language
of leadership you look at a victim and
they say things like this is a problem
I've got a problem right here or I'm
really scared about this or I hate that
client or I hate this work or I'm sick
of this day or I'm exhausted
or I don't like that or she never likes
me it's literally the language of
toxicity and the words you use really
are like a context or a framework or a
stained-glass window on the way you see
the world I mean here's a game-changing
insight you see the world not as it is
you see the world as you are you see the
world through a lens and your language
forms that lens of belief I mean your
lens of belief and your personal filter
on reality is not really a true filter
on reality it's just a filter on reality
that has formed as a result of all the
words you've picked up from the moment
you were born so when you were a little
baby
your mom and your dad use the language
that they were taught when they were
kids to use and if they use the language
of victim itis and if they leave you the
language of victimhood like well you
know you can't do this I hate this I'm
tired of this money doesn't grow on
trees be ordinary if you're successful
you'll be hated
all that messaging that we pick up from
our parents and the media and the world
around us and their peers the little
kids that we used to play with in the
playground or the friends that we had is
teenagers that will either lift us up or
tear us down so I guess what I'm trying
to say and hopefully I'm making the
point clearly for you but we see the
world through this personal filter and a
lot of this personal filter that drives
our performance and our behavior is
really constructed from the words that
we've picked up and then the words we
are taught to use and so the right-angle
turn for you to create exponential
energy mindset productivity creativity
results in the world results in your
life comes down to in part a really
intelligent use of your words and like I
said at the beginning of this mastery
session most people are really
unconscious about their words and that's
why most people are not getting rare
error results so what are some of the
words I encourage you to shift from well
don't talk about what you hate to do
talk about what you love to do don't
talk about problems talk about
opportunities don't talk about what
makes you tired talk about what makes
you inspired don't talk about your past
talk about your future don't talk about
what broke you your art talk about what
opens your heart don't talk about what
dis spirits you talk about what you are
fueled by don't talk about the things
within your life that are not working
talk about the things in your life that
are working don't talk about your pain
talk about your pleasure and you know if
I if I were sitting with you right now
coaching you I mean I am coaching you
and what I would encourage you to do as
soon as I finished this mastery session
is pull up your journal and if you're
not journaling please start journaling
because journaling is a ritual you want
to install into your days Joan Didion
said this I don't know what I think
until I write it down think about that I
don't know what I think until I write it
down and so in your journal after this
mastery
pull out a fresh page and draw a line
down the center of the page and write
about the language of victimhood and the
language of leadership leadership and
start to write down all the words you
use in the sentences you employ that
really are speaking that are really
victims speak and then in the other
column I want to start writing down the
language of leadership the language that
as of today you will be committed to
using so that you start to use the
language of someone who's world-class
and I've given you some examples but
doing that exercise will make it really
clear and as you know clarity breeds
mastery bottom line is this you are
built to be a leader you are not
constructed to be a victim and once you
get your words right you are going to
start noticing daily shifts in your
energy your focus your momentum your
confidence and your output and when you
start getting those words right you
start lifting your professional life
your personal life to a whole new level
of wow and guess what that is what you
are meant to do thank you guys so much
for watching I hope you enjoyed I'd love
to know what did you take from this
video that you're going to immediately
apply somehow to your life or to your
business leave it down the comments
below I'm super curious to find out I
also want to give a quick shout out to
Clark technically Clark thank you so
much a picking up a copy of my book your
one-word and doing that interview on
your channel I really really really
appreciate this apartment and I'm so
glad that you enjoyed the book about his
new book your one-word thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon